so winter may be coming but apparently
it's not going to last forever
hey guys hope you like this as a
background better i feel it's a little
more dynamic than the couch although
you'll be stuck with that as i wrap up
the episode by episode reviews on game
of thrones season 3 but that brings me
right to the fact that the producers of
game of thrones have now gone on record
that they only plan for the show the
last seven or eight seasons i know that
sounds a little bit wishy-washy for them
to not settle on an exact number but
their point was
they're going to end it when they get to
that what
but the point is they intend to end it
when they reach a natural conclusion
where they need to end this thing
they're not going to wait around and
string along several seasons waiting for
george rr martin's notoriously late
books right now george rr martin has two
more books on the song of fire and ice
series to finish and get released and
given historically how long the gaps
between his books tend to be there is a
very real possibility that the last book
is not gonna be out for about a decade
so what does that mean for the end of
the show are they gonna make something
up are they gonna pull it completely out
of their butt no george r.r martin who
has been working fairly closely with the
producers on this show has sat down with
him and basically laid out what he
currently has planned for the end of the
show going through each character now
it's broad strokes it's not details
because that'll get worked out when he
sits down to actually write the thing
but it does empower the producers to be
able to wrap this thing up in their own
time and not have to either give us a
ridiculously long gap in between seasons
or to give us multiple seasons of
nothing but filler so i say good for
them and good for us as fans because it
means that things are going to maintain
some degree of integrity
although i do have to say for people who
are fans of the books first if this does
come to pass that the show wraps up
before the books do it's going to kind
of suck for them they're they're
basically going to have the last book or
possibly even two books spoiled for them
by the tv show but you know so it goes i
say props to the producers for making
the right call fingers crossed that what
this actually does is kick george our
mark
is kick george rr martin in the ass to
get these books finished before the show
catches up with it but who knows
normally at this point i'd ask your
opinion on something game of thrones
related but you know what i want to get
your opinion on all this how does this
look this feel better feels a little bit
more dynamic to me a little
got a little more freedom of movement
i'm digging it are you leave a comment
down below let me know if we're heading
in the right direction in the meantime
this council is adjourned